of course women are funny why I'm you
know what what some of my best friends
are funny ladies I mean well you know I
don't I don't understand maybe they're
using maybe when they talk about women
not being funny maybe in kind of not in
the way that we're you know young male
humor is used maybe it's more in a more
intelligent way that women use comedy
there's all kinds of comedy there's will
ferrell movies and there's Larry David
on Curb Your Enthusiasm one I enjoy
totally and one I just don't so I think
you know it's the way you use it there
was an article written in Vanity Fair i
was at Vanity Fair one of the women
aren't funny well I think he was talking
about the way women use humor men use
humor to get something out of the
relationship where women don't use it
that way I think that's the difference
and every time I hear about women not
being funny I think women are no
terrific I think they're equal I think
everybody's equal in it there are less
women comedians around them their men
I'd say that's about twenty percent
women comedians compared to men I don't
know maybe I I don't know maybe because
of the work that goes into it it's a
very company's very aggressive I mean
it's hard you're out every night trying
to write material perform material so
it's it's grueling and you have to have
that kind of drive inside of you to do
it I mean to make it a lot of these
these community comedians are on the
road all the time and it's it's not the
easiest life and it's not the easiest
life it hanging around a club's every
night also so you can't really want it
and be able to to get on stage most you
know for at least 10 years and doing
that stuff that's a long time
I like Lisa Lampanelli I like Susie
Essman I like Lynn caplets I like my
friend joy behar Judy gold I don't want
to leave anybody out of this there are a
number of young women around coming up
the ranks Jessica kirisin there's a lot
of ladies working in New York